And it's time for Drew's News,
your friendly news gardeners
planting those good news seeds.
And with me at the desk,
best co-pilot on the planet,
and I do mean that, Rossy Ross Mathews.
Hi, hi, everybody!
(audience clapping)
Spring, sprung!
Today, I'm really excited,
because we have an epic desk guest.
She is a writer, an actress, an entrepreneur,
and you can catch her on the seventh and final season
of "Grace and Frankie."
Please welcome our dear friend to the show,
June Diane Raphael!
Oh my god, it's good to be here.
It feels right.
It feels really right.
I mean, you and your often collaborator,
Casey Wilson,
were kind enough to come on the show
when nobody knew what it was.
We were in the height of a pandemic.
And thank you for taking that leap with us back in the day.
Are you kidding me?
(audience clapping)
What?
And then, fun fact.
Your husband, Paul,
is the first person
who brought the Drew's News Zoom to life.
Oh yeah, the background.
And we've followed his model ever since.
But he's the origin story.
That's her husband, Paul Scheer.
(audience clapping)
Should I be expecting like some commission on this show?
There might be a residual check in the mail.
Do I get a cut?
Yeah, you do.
I should.
Speaking of cuts, that dress, you are looking so beautiful
and you work alongside of two legends,
Lily Tomlin and Jane Fonda.
This is the final season of "Grace and Frankie."
The show has lasted seven seasons.
It's crazy.
Seven!
And it's so good.
I love it so much.
And listen, so it's interesting
to kind of talk about it now 'cause it's coming out,
the final season premieres April 29th,
but we finished in November.
Any fun, fly on the wall, surprises
about the icons of Jane and Lily
that come off the top of your head.
I mean, I think they were very nervous to work with me.
You know what I mean?
Just to be in the presence of a legend.
That's right.
You're damn straight.
And icon.
So I just tried to tell them
like I'm just a regular gal, you know?
Like there's nothing to be worried about.
So sweet of you.
I think the thing I love
the most about them is how often
both Jane and Lily use Siri.
Whoa, really?
Yeah.
I love this!
That's so fun!
It's just, I mean, I'm using Siri very occasionally.
You know, very judiciously.
But they are fully transcribing texts to people
and full emails, new paragraph.
They're fully living their lives on Siri.
Ah, this is the best tip ever, I love it.
I love this intel.
It's so interesting.
I feel like Siri doesn't like me.
But if it's good enough for Jane and Lily,
it is good enough for everyone, but me.
(upbeat music)